اللقطه الاخوان فعلا تقشعر لها الابدان
هذه هما اللبؤات الاطلس الحقيقيين هذه هي
مثال للمراه المغربيه الصبوره التي تصبر
مع راجلها في السراء والضراء وتكبر
وليداتها ومبادره للخير بدون شروط
ومزايدات مغربيات يحملن احجار البناء على
ظهورهن ويصعدن به في الجبل لبناء مسجد في
قريه امن دار النائيه متحديات الدروب
الجبليه
لنقل الاحجار مسافه قدرت ب 300 متر من
المكان الذي صفت فيه مواد البناء الى موضع
المسجد في قريه امن دار الامازيغيه بضواحي
مدينه مراكش في مشهد وثقه صانع المحتوى
المغربي وامين منير واثار اعجاب رواد
التواصل الاجتماعي واشادت به الهيئه
الديمقراطيه المغربيه لحقوق الانسان التي
ارفقت منشورا لها بوسم تحيه للمراه
المغربيه الحره بامثالهن يفتخر المغرب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]